bonn/eschborn die spalter stemmer force
bonner es gibt ein sponsoring aktiv ist
campbell soup aktiv ja ja nein ja das
denke ich kämpfe gegen unendlich viele
spyder schwarz-weiß bonner nonstopnews
von kann die weißenborner spawnen
nonstop an die sportsbar die monsters
pochen bonn eschborn
die spot alte stürmer vor stoner es gibt
ein sportsmann der spawn andrack
vordergrund eines von minecraft wurde
der spot nein also der der des pons
bonner um einen rum
die arena des bonners wollen nichts
bonner sondern die spawn monster die
gehälter hatte die beute bis zum
richtigen sportart vor ein erwischter
diesen weg
mache ich noch eine etage für etage wie
das weitergeht
jeden fall trumpf mein haus über allen
anderen dass du das heftige h weiter so
auf einer höhe irgendwie dann komme ich
das und doch das ist gut für das geil
ich bin sowieso ist scheiße ist falsch
gebaut absolute kellerkind merke ich
habe alles falsch gebaut
wirklich naja hab ich kannst du wieder
abholen das ist das ärgerliche kommt
schon spontan oder witzig bau alles sind
und wir realisieren das ist falsch
gebaut hat also so langsam wird es hier
echt anstrengend
man habe sauber starb jungs wo nein ich
will nicht den zauber stadt gemacht und
er nebenbei auch noch gewalt alter das
heißt darf mein chef gar nicht mehr so
exzessiv nutzen wie es eigentlich tue
oder wenn ich im sommer starb muss ich
aufpassen kommt papa wurde ein flop
er zeigt uns wo der frosch die locken
hat beim porsche wieder 23
ja okay geht auf jeden fall schneller
dann mache ich das einfach so ich habe
jetzt schon 18 mini um scherben oder 32
seit es geht wirklich recht gut hier und
vor allem köpfchen 32 level also
eigentlich mega chillig
90 minuten sterben so gefällt mir das 90
du brauchst du eigentlich so viele
steine ja weil als ist ein bug weniger
automatischen crafting table die beine
das eigentlich nur ein app kann
unendlich machen aber ich nutzer
verschiedene crafting paypal
gleichzeitig sich dafür allein schon mir
dass ich möchte drei stück und aber das
ist ein bug weil sozusagen ihr mit
haltbarkeit gerechnet wird die miliz
scherbe kann man nicht nur an ihrem
scheibe rein kommt und das wasser muss
dahinter eine kiste hinstellen wo die
mini umstadt drin ist damit sozusagen
die automatische werk band denkt aha und
container hinter mir
dennoch sozusagen unendlich ecke in
scherben beinhaltet und ja deswegen bei
euch doch als man das noch mal erklären
möchte mir das gleich aufbaue
erst dagegen wenn das aufbau oder
wettkampfmäßig hast du ja dann einen
vorteil
ich bin glaube ich werde hier am
wenigsten wettkampf sieht alle seine
wasser gab es scheiße ich hab einfach
ich hab am wasser gebaut weil ich bock
dazu hatte sie doch scheiß aus berlin
sein ob lasten bald werdet ihr wahl
menschen gebissen
der ronny kläfft etwa recht und wer von
mir also komme es nun darauf an dem
zusammen auf welche sehen das kommt
drauf gekommen ist
jetzt könnt ihr mal wieder drop und zu
studio des pornos es lebt ja bald nicht
mehr möglich so jetzt spornen oder nie
weiter als 20 millionen
und jetzt freunde eigentlich wollte ich
nämlich die kfz-steuer für jede folge
oder so macht und zwar wollte das
eigentlich alles hier hinsetzen
ich stelle mich auch kurz mal hin naja
kann den ganzen scheiß wow ich habe
schon 64 fäden als ob doch plötzlich ein
werk machen
ich hab sogar mehr als 460 finden sich
gerade die truppen auf andy cave spiders
und in kirchzarten bogen gesorgt dass
ganz komisch ist aber die zyklischen
bogen gedruckt und eine lothar hat magic
ist das dann aber ich ihn mir vorstelle
und du willst die dog minimum scherben
spin augen und fehden ernst young grad
richtig gefruchtet
22 18 stück alter denke mein alter ist
das 20 alter ich muss das alles hier
wieder neu aufbauen
das ist einer meiner lieblings wolf
garten richtig appetit ja wo man eine
sache waren so richtig bock drauf als
franzi milch für diese ist etwas wo ich
sage ganz ehrlich wohl bekomm's
mann ich hab kein bock das jetzt alles
neu zu bauen halte das nicht so auf ich
war schon so weit
hier habe ich einfach mal etwas abgebaut
und einer muss den dschungel fliegen
toll war das jetzt einfach weil simon ab
einfach weil der mir alles kaputt
gemacht hat soll ich brauche zwei
blättern seinem bau macht ganz oben
jetzt kommt müsste jetzt noch einen film
knast doch die ist nicht mal aufgeladen
kann ich nicht machen
manno
warum es aufpassen also hier oben ist
alle drei kann ich ganz entspannt stehen
und lädt sich alles auf
da kaum drobny - scherben noch zehn
stück wie gesagt
8 cm hoch
egal ist dass ich dem 1 x 1 tunnel in
etwa mein gott
ja ich bin gestorben
häufig gewesen
da ist fast leer
damit schneller zu fuß es war irgendwann
so viele spinnen tatsächlich
durchstreife jetzt das grundstück ist
alles scheißegal zu meinen sachen bauen
kann
mein gott oh mein gott schafft cats oder
schafft er es nicht also ich sag mal so
ich wächst ziemlich sicher schaffen vor
allem ich bin in meiner angst gestorben
da wurde ganz weit weg
500 meter dass er nächstes jahr laufen
laufen
20 was heißt du billig keine tiere nur
energie oder wo sie ist immer die die
politik ja das ist halt meine ich also
ich man kann wenn man auf ein item drauf
klickt mit irgendeinem links mit einem
mittigen die acht glaube ich war es oder
eben nicht
das achter gegen den buchstaben oder
einer zahl sowie mit wenn man kräftig
dass man sich was man daraus machen kann
ja da sieht man die haltbarkeit
vergeblich schaufelt und so die viele
blöcke man darf noch abbauen kann zum
beispiel meinen spitzhacke dann kann es
insgesamt 500 abbauen und ich hab noch
234 damit abholen kann
weiter vom hals halten dann sieht auch
die langener mittwoch fliegen keine
sekunde also nähe beim beim jetlag ist
es halt anders
das ist halt genau mein ort zum gleichen
zeitpunkt
ich musste jetzt klappen vor allem
wertvoller zeitverlust ich muss das
ganze gehen 130 meter und ich hoffe wenn
mich jetzt die blakes abschießen und die
sonderfall dann ist meine sachen weg
direkt einmal 14 uhr
ran an die mutterbrust
wo ist schon ungefähr
okay da fliegen einige bleche alles klar
in der ecke und fast gestorben wenn ich
jetzt ein abschied nicht dauernd ja ja
und dann bin ich weg und kommt immer
mehr skelette
ich kann ja ich bin ja ich hab sogar
aufgeladen wenn du das verlierst alter
dann hast du kräften ist und ich könnte
das hundertmal kräften
ich muss nur schnell habe ich dann einen
jumpen kann zudem entschlossen vor
meinem grundstück toll wie solche
einfach gut drauf kommen
man kommt ohne dreher wird nicht laufen
ich habe es also erstmal die
allesklar.com schon in spinden sachsen
bin ich schneller ne ich muss innerhalb
von fünf minuten da sein weil ich einmal
den chart habe alle meine sachen weg
zweiter tank einmal reloaded ist hat man
fünf minuten zeit
ich habe die uhr im blick rechts
veranstalter
ja ich nicht mal jetpack 991 die uhr
arbeitet gegen mich sehr dass doch schon
heute cheb eger wenigstens eine chance
aber direkt hoch und dann ins loch
sie muss man irgendwie ablenken ich hab
keine angst dass meine ganzen sachen
wechseln er hat sie durch 20 du dich
gefühlt hast im netz ach du scheiße komm
schon
us sprinter wie sagte doch wie hunger
folter nicht so gelungen
jetzt steht beck an
gutachter ich dachte wenn ich am start
eine woche fliegt direkt wieder weg am
schlimmsten stirn die glänzt wie die
stirn von harry potters hinterkopf aber
ich finde es scheiße das wollte ich auch
graf fragen was war klar die stirn von
seinem hinterkopf und warum glänzt die
das würde nur gehen wenn dieser
professor kreml werde
er wollte model hinterkopf hat muss
nicht auf mein grundstück kommt das kann
ein problem
ich glaube hier ist an und ich finde die
das heft aber ich hab ja okay okay ich
sammle ich spinne
verzieh dich wo auf fast 1000 wieder
fest dauert und ich gehe nicht auch
nicht ob ich rege mich erst mal ich
komme auch gleich wieder ins tarp zurück
muss nun meinen restlichen sachen kurz
auf einen herzens noch kurz alles regen
also habe ich alles da so sein jet werk
war erstmal so aufgeladen
weil ich meine long vollmuth wenn
diamanten helm und warum ist doch mein
jüngster sohn main
nein
nein das feedback ich bin des todes des
tores
was hast du alter alter so knapp war das
noch nie altobelli das ist ein alter
berlin
es ist ein ausdruck für what the [ __ ]
ach du schreck zurück ich dachte ich hab
das jetpack aufgesetzt dabei habe ich
mein bett pack aufgesetzt das genauso
aber nicht fliegen kann ich wollte
hochfliegen einem halben herzen hat er
noch zwei spinnen getötet dann könnt ihr
es wieder wenn man inventar gehen uns
wechseln
walter ich muss kurz einmal unten gucken
ob wirklich jetzt einfach mal so viele
spinnen will jetzt meine sachen
herausholen und jetzt letzte spiele
dauern und erst eine okay ist so so so
okay ich war wirklich 24 mini
umschreiben weg.de wegpunkt was für ein
atom sie sagt mir leider nichts
möchte mit dem schlagen
das war der hammer das war echt der
hammer das hat mich wieder richtig
wachgerüttelt
ich möchte meine sache wieder ein
jetpack also ich komme auch
freundlicherweise mit dem jetpack und
wenn ich komme ist aufgeladen komplett
wieder zurück also ich langsam unterwegs
auch beim fliegen bei meinen solarien
produziert mehr energie als wenn ich
ganze durchgehend letters drücken würde
wie lange noch 700 meter noch den zaun
machen
nassgeschwitzt gar nicht mehr
24 - scherben
das ist nur schon ein guter anfang von
meter zu meter titel
ich kann echt nicht mehr also bin fix
und fertig
nein
herr thielen
wieso wie mache ich mir ja besser ziegel
in dem du via post als ob muss ich die
abbauen
klappt der ziege kann man nur in der
festung abbauen das wars oder den
deutschen smelter sehe ich gerade
wirklich netter reckin induction was
sind in warin gott ging war in gott gott
aus ingwer und dazu brauche ich das
das ist so ich bin da ja
ich guck mal was conny macht jetzt
gewährleisten hier oben da bin ja mal
gespannt so ein komisches rotes blut ist
pinocchio ding ja egal ich brauche meine
jetpack fw32 motivation aber ich musste
zurückkommen
ich danke dir
dadurch lastet auf das ausland
kleines präsent dass du das schon hier
ist ein jetpack ich nehme so faden 12 1
präsenz muss sein
danke sehr nett zum glück hat das hat
mir echt den rest gegeben
ich hab eigentlich wurst so die aussagen
machen wir hier ein katz und leute
vergesst nicht bleibt immer gleich egal
was passiert und wenn sie bei uns beim
nächsten mal
machs gut ist an ciao ciao